Rob Hale is a businessman entrepreneur
and philanthropist he's based in Quincy
Massachusetts which is about 10 miles
south of Boston and he is the founder
and CEO of granite telecommunications
Granite is a telecommunications
wholesaler that sells exclusively to
large businesses and government
organizations so what that means is
granite does not manufacture or own any
of the cable or wireless equipment that
its clients use to access their phone
systems rather Granite buys or leases
that stuff from large phone companies
like at T Verizon and cable companies
like Comcast and Charter and then it
flips it to customers at a markup but
not before installing its own software
which enables Granite to become its
clients outsourced I.T departments so
Granite customer service team oversees
all the network operations for its
clients phone systems
While most corporations have moved their
phone systems onto the internet many
still rely on landlines or pots lines
short for plain old telephone service to
power their critical services in stores
these are fire alarms security systems
and elevator lines that need redundancy
what interested me about Hale's story is
how somebody could build a 21st century
fortune on the back of a 150 year old
technology
Granite pioneered the wholesaling
business for analog phone lines these
are the Twisted copper wires that have
their origins in the 19th century when
Alexander Graham Bell patented uh the
telephone system there's still a need to
manage those pots lines and what Hale
did was he innovated off of that Legacy
technology and found value in it where
others did not
the lessons that I learned coming out of
a you know a private company that went
public
were
understand your strengths and your
weaknesses and control your own destiny
so Granite doesn't have any debt we're
20 years old now we're about at 1.8
billion dollars in Revenue we don't have
any debt
we don't have any and outside investors
so we control our own financial destiny
building a network is complex and
expensive especially 20 years ago it's
gotten because of Technology it's gotten
dramatically less expensive
but building and running a network is a
is a is a skill set that we needed to
grow over time and we probably didn't
have it at that time what we've always
had is this skill set for getting and
keeping customers work we're great on
the customer relationship side of this
business
Hale founded a company called Network
Plus in 1990 when he was 23 years old he
had had two Telecom sales gigs and he
saw an opening in the market uh which
was providing small business customers
with long distance telephone service the
first eight or so years of this business
were solid for Hail they netted margins
around 10 11 percent uh they didn't
carry any debt things were going well so
after legislation in 1996 opened up the
local phone market to competition
investors started throwing money at
telecom companies that were laying down
cable and were building physical
networks so Hale moved his business from
the wholesaling model and into the
network building model and so that
required a lot of capital so Network
plus took on over 200 million dollars in
debt
we went public in June of 99. that we
were those sexy stocks that uh there was
so much demand that the stock opened at
a level much higher than the original
trade was proposed so we were supposed
to open trading at 16 in fact the first
trade opened at 26 over the next nine
months the stock went all the way up to
63. I owned 27 million shares so I had a
billion four next to my name but then
after the.com crash things all Came
Crashing Down Network plus hadn't had
the time to actually build that Network
so it was left hanging essentially and
the company declared bankruptcy in
February of 2002 sold its remaining
assets for less than 16 million dollars
just a few years after reaching
evaluation of 3.4 billion by investors
and Hill was forced to lay off hundreds
of employees you know I had the the
local news newspaper when we were high
on the hog used to list me on the front
page there's the boy billionaire
and then when we were bankrupt they used
to list or going into bankruptcy they
listed me as the busted boy billionaire
and and those you know those are things
you never forget
I needed to reclaim my dignity I needed
it like I I'm telling you like I need
oxygen I needed that so I was eager to
rebuild quickly and there honestly there
was never a thought in my mind that we
wouldn't I knew February 4th of 2002 and
I in my soul I worked as hard as I could
to make sure the network plus survived
as best possible and as many people as
possible kept their jobs but on February
5th of 2002 I was full steam ahead we're
going to start a new business and we're
going to win this time I remember like
it was yesterday we were closing the
books on October of the second year and
we'd the controller called me it was
like seven o'clock at night and I was
walking across the street and we had
made about a 565 000 profit for that
month
which was up a couple of hundred
um
and I remember thinking like almost
weeping we made it like this is gonna
work
[Music]
so Hale has personally given along with
his wife Karen who's closely involved in
their philanthropic decision making over
280 million dollars to various
hospitals universities schools and
smaller community-based organizations
this year he and Karen are doing
something different they're giving one
million dollars per week to a new small
community-based charity to help these
groups set up endowments which they can
draw down upon for years to come the
idea is to help give these Charities a
more sustainable financial future
and part of Hale's story with
philanthropy too is that Granite is one
of the most philanthropic corporations
in America it's given 225 million
dollars to various Charities over its
two-decade existence and philanthropy is
core to hails persona but also to
Greenwich brand it's helped make the
company known locally as well as
nationally for uh the good works that it
does
[Music]
Karen and I uh subscribe to the
philosophy Maya Angelou articulated to
whom much is given much is expected we
have had great Fortune
and I'm certain none of that good
fortune none of those good tidings would
have befallen us if it weren't for our
community so first of all it seems very
logical to me that the community gave us
these opportunities we should try to
reward bring our rewards back to the
community
Boston's renowned for a lot of things
but at front and center is education and
Healthcare and so Karen and I feel like
a gift to Boston Healthcare is actually
like a triple dip it's a one gift
affects three different constituents
first if we give money to an institution
like Dana Farber or children's hospital
or Brigham Women's Hospital which are
all great institutions that we are
honored to support it's going to help
our community because it makes that
hospital in our community better so the
care they're going to provide to our
community is lifted but secondly these
are
number one number three and number nine
ranked hospitals in the world
at their skill sets
the medicine that's going to come the
research that's going to come from these
institutions is going to change the
world
and so the cure to cancer for in
particular we focus on pancreatic cancer
I believe it's going to be found in
Dana-Farber and and some of the
medicines and the early indicating
research that they're developing will
affect the world
so it's a gift to impact the world and
then finally we're Boston family we want
Boston to flourish and what Boston is
best at among a few other things is
medicine so if we can make our medical
institutions even better
than Boston gets better so when we give
to to Healthcare in Boston it feels like
we're getting extra reward for each
single gift
foreign
[Music]